Stanley spent most of his career as the writer,
director,
editor and producer of marvel comics.
He created some of the world's most popular comic book characters like
Spiderman,
iron man,
the hulk,
and the rest of the Avengers.
While started out as the creative ideas of a teenage boy evolved into one of the
most profitable movie franchises in all of history down biographics,
we're going to talk about the legendary life of Stanley
[inaudible].
On December the 28th of 1922 Stanley Martin Libor was born in New York City.
His parents,
Jack and Celia,
where Romanian Jewish immigrants who left for a better life in the United
States.
His father was a tailor,
but he was laid off during the Great Depression,
so they were constantly struggling to make rent.
His parents could only afford a one bedroom apartment and they did their best to
provide for their son.
His mother and father slept on the couch and allowed him to have a real bet.
Most of the memories Stanley had of his father was seeing him sitting at the
kitchen table,
flipping through the want ads in the newspaper trying to find a new job.
These were usually gigs that never lasted very long.
Eventually his father would find steady work and their lives would improve at
least a little.
When he was nine years old,
his mother gave birth to his younger brother,
Larry,
I'm saying.
Yeah,
he got a bicycle for Christmas.
Stan took this opportunity to ride his bike all over New York City and hardly
spent any time at home getting to know his younger brother sins.
His parents were struggling so much with money.
They encourage stand to get good grades so that he would have a brighter future
than they did and they encouraged him to find part time jobs as soon as he
could.
It took this very seriously and even skipped a few grades so that he could
graduate from high school sooner.
He attended an all boys school and since he was so much smaller and younger than
his cost made see struggle to make friends.
It was often daydreaming about his favorite movies and often had his nose in a
book.
As soon as he was old enough to work,
he got his first job at a garment factory.
The year later he moved on to become an usher at a movie theater called the
Rivoli.
He loved this job because he was allowed to see as many movies as he wanted for
free.
It was also able to make money doing something that he enjoyed and it also helps
him to relieve as parents financial stress.
He begins to pay for his own expenses so that his parents could focus mostly on
his brother Larry,
even at a young age,
his parents and teachers could tell that he would grow up to be someone special
at this stage in his life stat.
Imagine that he would be more involved in the movie business is either an actor
or maybe a screen right at his favorite movie growing up was the 1935 film
captain blood,
which was about swashbuckling pirate adventures.
He loved the elaborate fight scenes and would often imagine becoming the hero of
these films at 15 years old.
Stan ends at a writing contest for the New York Herald Tribune.
He wasn't and the editor reached out to him to say that he should pursue writing
as a full time career.
Seeing as he had high school early,
he was able to get a job writing a bitters for a newspaper.
That's after a while he felt that this was pretty boring and indeed quite
morbid,
so he tried to see what other opportunities were out there for young writers was
16 years olds.
He got a job at timely comics assisting that artist,
Jack Kennedy ends the head writer,
an editor or Simon,
the overarching publishing company actually made most of their income from pulp
fiction and comics were more of an afterthought for them.
In the beginning,
Stan was pretty much hod just to make coffee and erase the pencil marks on Jack
Kirby's drawings as well as do various other errands.
Hasn't gone was any $8 a week and if we consider inflation,
that's about $141 today.
So back then timely comics followed the trends of whatever was popular at the
time.
Now DC comics within main competitor and they had superman,
so the characters they created,
we'll often they recycled idea in one way or another.
At this point in time,
Jackie Kirby and Joe Simon has already been inventing superheroes like the human
torch and Captain America.
Stan was eager to move on from just making coffee,
so he pitched a story for a captain America scripts off to the third issue was
published.
They liked his ideas and they agreed to use it in the following issue.
This is when he decided that his pen name would be Stan Lee,
which is just as first named Stanley's,
but at half.
He figured that someday he could move on to become a novelist under his real
name standing the Martin Neba when he was 18 years old,
Stanley,
you had been working at timely comics for two years and he was assisting Jack
Kirby and Joe Simon with all the various duties of that company.
Both Kirby Simon were having a financial dispute with marvel comics as publisher
Martin Goodman,
and they decided to quit.
Stan was the only one left and his lost Austin.
If he would be willing to step into the role of head writer,
editor and Art Director.
This was meant to be a temporary fix.
Well,
Goodman searched for an experienced replacements,
but it's stat and actually ended up being great at doing all of these jobs at
once.
At the time,
he mainly focused on producing the captain American comics because you know,
the 70 24 hours in a day and he already had his work cut out for him.
At that time,
the comic book industry,
it was absolutely booming because people,
they wanted to escape the fears that they had about the war by reading stories
of heroes both in the newspapers and in fiction World War Two at this point,
it was absolutely raging.
Jack Kirby and Joe Simon.
They'd already established a theme of Captain America coming face to face
without Offit and on more than one occasion.
So Stanley carried on the legacy by acting out his fantasies of being in combat
overseas,
Captain America comics and spired Stanley to become a real hero himself.
He stays is I myself,
got so caught up in all of that.
Next thing I knew I had enlisted in the army.
I fell it's all nation,
was really in danger and so I couldn't live with myself if I were a civilian and
other people wherever that fighting.
However,
Stanley was not expected to go overseas and fight.
The army recruiter looked over his resume and gave him the job of playwright.
He was told to stay in the United States and write scripts for training films
and public service announcements that were shown to soldiers even if this was
not exactly the fight that Stan was looking for.
This was actually a pretty big deal and all of the army play went on to have
successful careers including Theodore Geisel,
who is better known as Dr Seuss.
So when he was 23 years old,
Stanley was discharged from the army and he moved back to New York City to
return to his job where the name had been changed from timely comics to marvel
comics
when's only returned to New York City.
He began to go out on dates and attend a lot of parties and do.
He was actually pretty embarrassed to tell people that he worked for marvel.
A lot of women would actually just walk away in mid conversation as soon as they
heard him say comic books.
Clearly these girls were not the one for him all his life.
Stan would be doodling pictures of the perfect girl that he always imagined that
he would find some day and it was like you could see a vision of the future.
One night he showed up to a party when a young woman named June Clayton on,
so the door stand was shocked because this was the exact same girl he had been
dreaming about his entire life.
He blurted out,
hello,
I think I'm going to fall in love with you.
Joan laughed and she thought this and the fact that he wrote comics was actually
quite charming.
The only issue was that she was married to someone else.
She was originally from England and she had become a war bride and moved to the
United States with a new husband to pursue a modeling and acting Korea.
She ended up fast husbands.
They were no longer happy together and once she met Stan,
she knew that it was time to make her divorce official.
When Stanley was 25 the do you got married and instead of having a fancy wedding
or a honeymoon,
they use that money to move to long island where they lived in a penthouse
apartment.
When Joan first got pregnant,
she painted that entire house pink because she wanted a daughter so badly.
This early works and she gave birth to a baby girl named June Juni out who they
nicknamed JC.
A couple of years later,
they had a second daughter named Jen.
Sadly,
Jen died after only being alive for seven days.
This was such a traumatic experience for Joan that she didn't want to have
children again.
They tried to a dark twist.
They run into a lot of issues.
Since Dan was Jewish and Joan was episcopalian,
nearly every adoption agency rejected them because of the differences in
religious beliefs.
While all of this was very tragic and difficult for Stanley and his wife opened
up his eyes to so many issues in the country that he had been unaware of until
this point.
Indeed,
it would become a catalyst for his motivation to inspire other people
[inaudible]
as work.
Stanley was still incredibly dedicated with his time at marvel comics.
They called their staff the bullpen because they were pumping out a one complete
comic every working day.
He made sure to give everyone on the team credits with the names on the cover of
each comic book,
which was brand new for the time.
He also gave the group the nickname of the Marion marvel and marching society
after he established more of a leadership role in the company's down.
Eventually convinced artists Jack Kennedy to returns a marvel comics since he
was one of the most talented men in the business.
Cubbies.
Artwork brought Stanley's ideas to life in a way that no one else could,
even though he was not an accident in the traditional sense,
Stan was known for acting out the roles of the characters when working as
Marvel's editor,
Erin's awesome director in order to explain what he was looking for in the
storyline,
rather than giving an office stay fully written script to follow,
Stanley would give them a general story,
nine of what was going to happen and so he wanted everything to be overly
dramatic like people in a silent film.
Once the artwork was done,
Stan would go back and fill in the bubbles with the appropriate dialogue.
This cut down on time.
Significant man.
It was cool.
The marvel method in the 1950s they psychologist named Frederick what and claims
that comic books and television were corrupting the youth in America.
In 1954 the Senate subcommittee on juvenile delinquency announced the comic
books were actually dangerous.
They started the comics code authority,
which puts strict rules of censorship on what types of contents,
where to be allowed to be published in comic books.
Every new story line had to be approved by the comics code or authority as the
cover of the book would have the seal showing that it had been checked for any
indecent contents.
According to the rules,
the mention of any crime at all,
it was enough to have a comic rejected this censorship.
It was a devastating blow to marvel who made their bread and butter on superhero
stories about fighting crime.
Stanley had to lay off almost all of the artists and they had to discontinue
many of that comics.
He was forced to write new stories that were aimed at young children and they
were incredibly bland and boring compared to writing about sue Harris.
Stanley trudged through this job for over a decade after working in the Comic
Book Industry for 20 Years.
Stanley was having a bit of a midlife crisis.
He had been writing these Sydney children's from experts so long that he really
wasn't sure he wanted to stay in the industry and DDT was already writing
screenplays and newspaper articles on the side and he was considering leaving
the comic book industry in order to write a novel.
The only problem was that he still had a wife and child to support and he
couldn't walk away from a paycheck.
He had a conversation with his wife,
Joan,
and she encouraged him to take a chance and try to write a comic for adults.
Even if it went against the censorship rules,
they decided that if it's published,
a hated it.
The worst thing that could happen was that he would be fired,
but well,
he was ready to quit anyways,
so really have nothing left to lose.
This is when he decided to create the fantastic four.
These characters,
they're multidimensional.
They didn't always enjoy having their superpowers.
They don't with very real issues with one another as well as they are in a
turmoil,
but that time superheros from both companies,
they were really one dimensional characters like captain America or or Superman.
It turns out that the audience responded really well to the fantastic four and
this ended up becoming extremely successful.
Lovell's published a couldn't deny the number,
so they continue to make more issues despite the disapproval and lack of stamp
from the Comics Code Authority.
Once he was able to express his ideas within the pages of marvel comics,
Stan Lee discovered a new love of the industry.
He began to create more characters like a man who he,
based on himself as a teenager,
each one of these characters was a direct reaction to the world around them.
For example,
the hope was written during the Cold War when people were afraid of nuclear
science.
Iron man was a response to the hates for the military industrial complex and the
x men where a social commentary on tolerance for people who are different from
us.
In 1966 Stanley created black panther who was the world's first black superhero.
He was revolutionizing to the industry and just about every single way during an
interview,
Stanley said that the 1960s and seventies well,
some of the best years of his entire career,
and again going on tours to universities around the United States.
By this point,
the children who grew up in the 1950s that we're told that comic books would
corrupt they're impressionable minds,
well embracing them once they reach their teens and that 20s young people,
everyone looked up to Stanley.
He gave lectures on story writing.
In reality,
Stanley was gathering data around his fans and his off to every Q and a session.
He was writing down notes about ways that he could improve the marvel comic
storyline.
In the 1970s Stanley became the head publisher of Marvel.
You decided to hand over the responsibility of the scripts,
do other writers on the marvel team.
As he tried to take the superhero characters to California,
he convinced the executives at marvel comics to let him move his family out to
Los Angeles and they opened up new offices,
gold marvel productions on the west coast.
It started the cartoon series of iron man is one called spider man and his
amazing friends.
In 1988 he became the head of marvel films and began to produce feature length
movies.
This ended up being a great business move because Spiderman,
he soon became a household name.
Unfortunately not everything that marvel studios produced was a success.
They tried to create a show called the amazing Spiderman,
which add on cvs,
but Stanley,
he thought it was awful.
He scheduled a meeting with cvs and tried to give some creative direction about
how to make the story better,
but they ignored his in Burton carried on doing it their way.
They should have listened to his advice because the show was canceled after just
four episodes.
Hollywood studios were having a hard time seeing the potential of these comic
book stories and didn't know how they put them on the big screen lease dated.
It's hard to explain the frustration.
We had these characters and we knew how they should be portrayed and there were
people who wanted to do them,
but nothing really jelled.
In 1997 the popularity of comic books drops dramatically.
Children were still watching the marvel animated series like x men on Saturday
mornings,
but the profits of the company went really downhill.
While it seems almost impossible to imagine this today,
marvel comics actually had to file for bankruptcy.
Thankfully,
even though the company was broke,
they still maintained the copyright to all of their characters,
which was a gold mine.
During this time of uncertainty,
Stanley was approached by investors.
You suggested that he start a whole new company called Stanley media,
which specialized in creating cartoons and comics that were streamed on the
Internet.
They started in 1999 and the venture became incredibly successful.
They were able to hire over 200 people to work on that stuff.
Unfortunately,
some of the executives were actually arrested for securities fraud.
It turns out they had taken advantage of Stanley's name and his reputation for
that own financial gain.
Stanley decided that the only way to avoid the scandal was to start his own
company called POW entertainment.
One of his most popular characters was stripped rela voiced by Pamela Anderson.
Eventually level was able to get back on their feet and they had Stanley under
contract so that they could continue to get as creative guidance to make sure
that the movies were done right.
After decades of dreaming of being on the big screen,
Stanley was finally about to appear in Hollywood blockbusters because he made
sure that his contract included cameo roles in each new marvel movie that came
out for the rest of his life.
Reassignments was not an option for Stanley.
He loved his job that much.
Stanley Martin Levy,
he passed away on November the 12th 2018 and it was 95 years olds and lives
every moment to the fullest with a sense of joy and enthusiasm.
Even if the man is gone,
the legend of Stanley will live on forever as being one of the most influential
people in comic book history.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
I've got brand new videos just like this every day of the week,
but if you're looking for something else to watch right now,
why not checking out some of the videos I'm linking to on the screen?
And as always,
thank you for watching
eight.